so the topic of this presentation is
active transport but let's review
passive transport first on the left of
this picture is diffusion notice how
there's a higher concentration of
molecules on the top of the membrane and
a lower concentration of molecules on
the bottom so through diffusion
molecules will diffuse downward until
there's an even distribution we've
reached equilibrium in the middle this
would be an example of facilitated
diffusion again there's a higher
concentration of molecules on the top
the membrane a lower concentration of
molecules on the bottom so through
diffusion molecules will diffuse
downward again until there's an even
distribution and we've reached what's
called equilibrium but these two
examples are examples of passive
transport no ATP energy was required for
this to happen now on the right hand
side let's introduce active transport
notice how there's a lower concentration
of molecules on the top and there's a
greater concentration of molecules on
the bottom and with the the help of ATP
molecules can actually be drawn and
transported from the lower concentrated
area to the higher concentrated area
let's explore this in more
detail so let's talk about active
transport in a little more depth it's
the movement of molecules across the
cell membrane but this time with the
help of
ATP and so we're going to look at some
types of active transport um first of
all the membrane pumps so here's a cell
membrane and and there's that green
object in the middle that's going to be
a membrane pump right there and now one
thing that pumps you should know whether
it's a bicycle pump like this or the
pedal pump that you step on pumps
require energy in order for a pump to be
operated you have to input energy and in
the world of cells the energy comes from
this molecule ATP adenosine
triphosphate and so what we're going to
see with uh active transport in the use
of membrane pumps is that molec ules get
pumped from an area of low to high
concentration now the brown circles in
my picture there's a a smaller
concentration on the bottom of the
membrane and so what we're going to show
you is that this is how molecules can be
moved up or against the concentration
gradient notice how a brown circle has
entered into the membrane pump with the
help of ATP ATP will actually cause that
membrane pump to change its
configuration thus releasing uh the
molecule
and so ATP actually changes the shape of
these membrane pumps or these what are
called carrier proteins notice how the
carrier protein went back to its
original shape and the process can be
repeated another Mo a brown molecule can
be pumped from a lower concentrated area
on the inside of the cell here is
another ATP molecule which changes the
shape of the carrier protein thus
releasing the brown molecule and so
again two examples where the molecule
has been pumped from a lower
concentrated area on the bottom of the
membrane to a higher concentrated area
on
top and eventually the pump res resets
and so the process can be
repeated you know here's a boat sailing
in the ocean and oh no it just crashed
into an iceberg and water is flooding
into the boat the boat might sink so
water's entering now a boat often has
what's called a BGE and a BGE is a water
pump that you can activate to uh if we
come back to this picture here uh a
water pump of the buge can just pump the
water back into the ocean so hopefully
if this ever happened uh the boat could
get to land or help could arrive to
evacuate the passengers and everybody
safe that's the idea of the buge now
what's my
point well here is a parium a
microscopic organism uh that lives in
watery
environments now it has an organal very
similar to a build let's explore
this so here's a simplistic animation of
a paramia living in a watery environment
and so through diffusion water simply
enters into the paramia from a high
concentration to a low and the paramia
can swell and swell and swell and
eventually pop and burst and of course
that would uh destroy and kill the
paramia and so if too much water
diffuses into the paramia it could swell
and burn first and die so what do they
do paramia have what's called a
contractile vacu a Contracting vacu and
it's activated it operates much like a
Bild now in order to activate this uh
contractile vacle they have to spend
some ATP energy but it's able to pump
water from the lower concentrated area
of inside itself to the higher
concentrated area out in the environment
and so it h it operates basically
basically a BGE to squirt out excess
water so it doesn't overinflate and
pop so here's another analogy here here
is a kayaker does this kayaker need to
spend his or her energy in order to move
up the river and I think the obvious
answer is yes this kayaker would have to
paddle very rigorously in order to move
from the lower area to the higher area
which would be up the river so in order
to fight the flow the natural flow of
the river you have to spend some energy
kind of like cells spend ATP energy to
pump molecules from a low to high
concentrated
area so another type of active transport
to mention is endocytosis let's break
that word down Endo means inside or
within cyto is the cell and osis is a
process so this is the process in which
the cell the cell through the cell
membrane through the plasma membrane
will take in substances so in my
animation here's a cell and here comes a
vesicle notice how the vesicle is
carrying the letter P the P might be a
protein let's say there's a protein
inside of that vesicle that the cell
desires and so what happens the vesicle
will fuse with the cell membrane and as
the vesicle fuses with the cell membrane
the protein is drawn inside of the cell
and now the cell has the protein inside
of it so notice how the cell kind of
just absorbed the the the vesicle and th
thus taking in the
protein so let's go over this example of
endocytosis here here's a virus right
here pretend and what we're going to
show you is that there's a uh there are
subcategories of endocytosis we're going
to look at the one known as phagocytosis
this is where a cell will swallow up
like a solid particle here comes a
special kind of white blood cell called
a fosite and what fyes do is they
perform
phagocytosis this white blood cell fosy
will begin to engulf and Surround and
basically swallow and draw inside of
itself the virus notice how the virus is
wrapped inside of a a vesicle now and so
this virus or maybe it's a bacteria
would eventually be killed when the
lomes of this white blood cell Fus with
the vesicle and inside of the lomes are
digestive enzymes that would destroy
this virus or this bacterium that could
be getting us sick so a great example
here of
endocytosis is the subcategory called
phagocytosis and so let's look at
another type of active transport really
the opposite
exocytosis well EXO means outside or to
exit cyto as we said earlier means the
cell and osis again is a process so this
is the process where substances are
expelled and released from a cell so
here we have the gray object is a
portion of the cell and you can see a
Gogi body and so what we're going to
show you is that like proteins and
nutrients and waste can be released from
a cell through exocytosis let's follow
that P for for protein inside of the GGI
body there's a a p right there for P for
protein so the Gogi body will wrap up a
protein inside of a protective vesicle
and then the vesicle will travel to the
cell membrane and the vesicle will
actually fuse with and become one and
join with the cell membrane and now
we're going to start to see exocytosis
how this protein is just released into
the outside as the vesicle was absorbed
into the cell membrane so vesicles will
often carry and release objects through
the cell membrane like we just saw
releasing that P that P for
protein
and so there you go there's a hopefully
a quick summary of active transport if
you're in my biology class pause the
video try to answer these seven
questions I'm happy to check your
answers before school or after school
one day thanks for
watching and so there you go there's a
hopefully a quick summary of active
transport if you're in my biology class
pause the video try to answer these
seven questions I'm happy to check your
answers before school or after school
one day thanks for watching